Tom Verducci joins us here on the show
how are you Tom I am well very yeah
would you agree Crash Davis over ray
Kinsella just in terms of baseball
movies if you got a vote yeah I would
the dialogue in that movie is just
fantastic and of course apropos to
today's game remember when crash goes
out to the mound and tells nuke LaLoosh
that strikeout they're overrated they're
boring they're fascists yes I use that
no Tom I mean and I guess we should get
into that because I mentioned that line
just last week when it appeared that may
came close to matching April in terms of
months in Major League Baseball where
more strikeouts than hits and the number
of balls that are not being put in play
right now what is that what is the major
league baseball stance on seeing the way
that this season is playing out from
that front Tom yeah listen you know
they've been concerned for the last few
years here about it's not the length of
the games it's the pace of the action
and that really is attributed both to
the ball not being in play often enough
it's a huge concern I think it's the
number one concern for baseball enriched
over the last decade or so I strikeout
the gun up they weren't that concern
because attendance has been Rocksteady
it really hasn't buried all that much
now all the sudden attendance is down
almost 7% and if it's paid at this level
you're looking at the lowest level in a
full season since 1996 it was the first
full year after the strike now all of a
sudden I think there's concern that the
marketability of the game and especially
tied to gate revenues is being harmed
because the ball just is not in play
enough and so what's the fix what's the
fix well I'll let you pick two of these
three options for me because what we've
had so far really is band-aids you're
talking about the intense automatic
intentional walk that limit on mound
visits they're really not affecting how
we proceed and watch the game I think
you could lower the mound you know less
of a plane is the plane on a delivery of
the pitch would put more balls into play
I think you could limit the roster of
pitchers to 12 because right now there's
so many relief pitchers
managers don't mind pulling starters out
of the game early and starters know that
so now starters are using a relievers
mentality and they're trying to strike
everybody else from the minute the game
starts and we saw the race user we saw
the Rays use a reliever as a starter Tom
that's happened exactly when you
extrapolate it out me like the worst
case scenario that you're playing a
whole game essentially with relief
pitchers who thinks that's entertaining
and it may work in terms of efficiency
but it's not fanned friendly and in my
final one would be a pitch clock and
that's Rob Manfred favorite one and he
backed off it this year because the
union was so upset about the slope
reagent market he didn't want to shove
that down their throats
but that's the one he leans toward and I
would agree that if you're talking about
one change the game that doesn't talk to
the actual strategy the game that would
make a difference in how you're watching
a baseball game that would be the one
that would give you the biggest bang for
the buck how does how would that put
more balls in play because the ball the
balls thrown more I mean what a
perception of ball in play that the time
between the ball and play would be less
so you're not you may not actually
affect the number of strikeouts but the
time that you wait for the ball to be
play would be reduced I would seem like
the game is moving faster well how about
this one Tom I'll go you one better get
rid of the shift
no more shift that you draw an imaginary
line right down the middle of the field
and nobody who is technically and
historically stationed on the left side
of the diamond like a shortstop or third
baseman may cross that line prior to a
pitch being thrown and the same vice
versa it's not sacrilegious you think
about the NFL right they've changed the
way that Todd defenders cover wide
receivers you know they really can't hit
him after five yards we think about the
NBA and then that outlawing that there's
own defense right I mean sports have
always
rebalanced offense defense and they put
their thumb on the scale to do that
sometimes it's harder to do that in
baseball because of tradition I would
say it's not a bad idea
but I would say wouldn't have the effect
that you think that it would it does the
shifts especially harm left-handed
hitter as you don't run well that's when
you really cover a huge amount of ground
to the pull side so it would have a
small impact but I don't think would
have a huge impact not as much as you
think well what about the mentality
though that people are trying to hit it
over the shift and pitchers are throwing
it further up in the strike zone exit
velocity on top of that is the mentality
at the plate thus more strikeouts
because they're trying to hit it over
the shift just that if you want to
reduce baseball to what the game is now
it's about the homerun it's about trying
to hit home run and on the other side
defending the home run right so when you
do that yeah you're gonna have more
swing and misses there's not as many
balls in play there's not as many hit
and runs or sacrifices or rallies or
singles or actually at an all-time low
so the idea of string hits together is
not happening so hitters do sell out it
would be like if the NBA was reduced to
nothing but 3-point shot and fouls so
yeah I think you know it's easy for us
to say just hit the ball to the other
side of the field but these guys now
have been trained to be rewarded for
hitting homeruns and hitting for power
and I will tell you this rich I think
the actual stuff pitchers bring to the
mound on a nightly basis is greater than
it's ever been
so that makes hitting more difficult
than it's ever been hmm Tom Verducci
here on the Rich Eisen show okay we are
approaching as we all know the summer
months and thus the trade deadline I'm
assuming since we talked about it before
the season before opening day that we'd
have to see how Baltimore season played
out before Manny Machado could be
available my gosh what an unmitigated
disaster in Charm City right now so I'm
assuming Machado is gone by the end of
July and the question is what's the
market yeah you know back up the truck
19 wins there and we're almost where we
are in the middle of June now yeah
Britton Brock you know and certainly
Machado and the price I think is they
missed a little bit of a window here
because I think the price has gone down
for because you're renting Manny not for
six months but for you know essentially
two months and
but listen I don't know they're gonna
break the bank I'm Manny Machado deal
you know I don't know that we've seen a
position player on the market like him
but the the ones closest to it like JD
Martinez last year at the return wasn't
fantastic you know I think the Dodgers
to me are still the best fit now if they
wait till the end of July then they can
fill
I think squeeze under the luxury tax
threshold who's really been their
business plan for this year so I still
think that's where he's going to wind up
but I think it's gonna be later rather
than sooner mm-hmm and so what about the
rest of the market you got teams that
couldn't add some pitchers Dodgers
putting another pitcher on the disabled
this might be one of them the Yankees as
well could use some firepower looking
down the road if they do face Houston
again when it's all on the line I think
the Yankees are the team to watch
because listen right now they're the
best team in baseball they're gonna win
way more than 100 games and yet in a
postseason environment if they match up
with Boston and or Houston to me they'll
never have a starting pitching matchup
in their favor and that's that's an
issue for a team that you know looks
like a juggernaut right for 162 games
we'll probably hit more home runs than
anybody but you go up against Boston
starting pitching against Houston
starting pitching and I'm not sure that
Sonny gray CC Sabathia must hironaka are
gonna win a series 7 Reno is fantastic
he can match up with just about anybody
and make that starting pitching matchup
awash but they won't have a matchup in
their favor problem I think the Yankees
and they do have enough talent and chips
to go get a big guy is is there gonna be
a big starting pitcher out there I'm
talking about a guy who can start one of
the first two games on postseason series
but just somebody you know j-hat Marcus
Stroman somebody's gonna fill in a
rotation in the regular season and I
don't think they're getting Jake degrom
they're not getting Noah syndergaard I'm
not getting Madison Bumgarner I mean
that's just you know fantasy league
wishlist for people looking at matchups
I think in reality it could be tough for
them to find that kind of a starting
pitcher
I'm sure they'll look hard in the
meantime they're hoping that Sonny gray
has turned a corner here and he's got
the stuff to be that kind of a guy it's
hasn't happened yet consistently with
the Yankee so when it's all said and
done do you think the fact that they
didn't sign they didn't they didn't
acquire Gerrit Cole when they may have
had the chance and then watched him go
to Houston that that could be the
difference maker when it's all said and
done it could be yeah it could be now
listen I think that fire I saw the
Yankees package they weren't really
thrilled with Clint Fraser so you know
what they thought fire it did they
thought I had a better package from you
stand hard to blame the Yankees for that
because they'd kept people who are doing
great for them who are and and cleaver
Torres and looks fantastic right
it's hard to knock them on that not sure
even the Yankees saw that Gerrit Cole
was gonna become this monster that he's
to come so but yeah I think there's no
doubt if we see another Yankees used in
series that's going to be a narrative
brought up many times as that Gerrit
Cole could be the difference maker in
that race or in that series great chat
Tom really appreciate it we'll see on
Friday night that's a I mean the NL the
NL is what you know looks like a total
free-for-all where everybody is in the
mix in the west to the east is a
three-team race the central you could
you could even you know here's a
three-team race wildcard where the
Pirates are five and a half out while
the the AL seems to be pretty much
solidified right now that's what it
looks like I agreed I think that I know
Central is gonna be my favorite race
because it's gonna be a high number of
wins among at least three teams right
and you know I still think there's a
possibility a wildcard coming out of the
West but brewers are legit cardinal
starting pitching is awesome and the
Cubs you have to say over the favorites
but the gap between the Cubs and those
other teams now is very small if there
is one Cubs and Cardinals on Friday
night on MLB Network Tom part of that
broadcast as well as uh this segment
thanks for calling Tom we'll chat soon
always fun thank you you bet right back
at you that's Tom Verducci here on the
Rich Eisen show the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience